même si j'en garde un bon soir bonsoir
alors quand on vous demande pourquoi m6
jean gabin parce que c'est vrai que vous
dites je pouvais pas prendre alain delon
parce que c'est un facho un trou de
balle exact ouais exact j'aurais pu
prendre un autre mot que jean gabin
pendant laquelle j'avais jean gabin
puisque dans les acteurs que j'aimais
bien quand j'étais plus jeune il y avait
jean gabin paul maurice principal
meurice et habib
sy bourobine alors vous êtes un fan faut
dire aussi des tontons flingueurs de
touche pas au grisbi de mélodie en
sous-sol
aux quatre coins de taille pour être
retrouvé
c'est bizarre mais sans la technologie
enfin c'est pas la wii vous êtes un fan
des photons flingueurs de touche pas au
grisbi de mélodie en sous-sol cc ou qui
à charles qui est un ancien braqueur
sait dans quel film c'est dans mélodie
en sous sol a dit un sous sol
j'entendais bien en fait parce que vous
vous êtes un ancien braqueur et puis
votre vrai prénom ses chars ses chars
ouais c'est peut-être pour ça que vous
avez pris m6 faisant couler de source
mais ça coulait de source nous
connaissent et jack lang oui je veux
juste à l'heure et je connaissais en
tant que ex ministre
fils de fritz lang
vous le connaissez vous béatrice chiche
en cabane connaître tous les rappeurs
vous l'aimez bien oui à part qu'un truc
dans sa chanson qui m'énerve un peu oui
dans sa chanson l'aller dit du mal de
bruit en voulait ben j'ai envie je sais
pas qu il explique ses raisons de toutes
vérités ne sont pas bonnes à dire il ya
longtemps donc à partir du moment après
c'est les sa divergent il ya des pour et
les contre et vu que tu es proche excuse
moi de te tutoyer tu vois donc voila
quoi parce que bon moment et ça réduit
vachon et ce qu'ils ont à défendre parce
que je connais qu'évidemment c'est des
gens que j'aime ouais mais maintenant le
diocèse non je trouve ça pas juste à moi
je trouvais ça se trouve ça juste dans
dans la mesure où je me dis que c'est
une génération
c'est la première génération de rappeurs
qui a eu cela n'ira ntm pas biais de
formats people et d'un bios ss ce sont
ceux-là qu'ils ont prôné on était contre
tours excusez-moi [ __ ] le système ils
sont rentrés les deux pieds dedans le
moulin intérieur clapet ils font
exactement la même chose que les gus qui
l'ont critiquée avant que tu m'excuseras
tu peux pas critiquer solareh me
balancer la gazelle derrière il ya un
truc je te regarde et je te dis ça va ma
gueule terrible chouette ouah c'est
grâce à ces c'est facile de prendre un
fanion voilà aujourd'hui c'est la misère
ou comme dans camp politique c'est la
sécurité qui
l'ont vécue et hiva supermarché tu vas
gagner vachement d'oseille tu vas pas
peut-être pas en profiter aussi ce que
je trouve sympa normal quoi tu vois je
serai prêt à ce que je fais avec mon
losail pour l'instant j'ai pas de fachos
pour les toucher non mais après quand
les mecs ont du succès on leur dit ouais
les mecs vous rentrer dans le moule
maintenant on sent qu'il est où il ya un
bon plan place nous donne a changé il
dénoncer des choses qu'ils ont vécu
qu'ils ont à un moment où est dénoncée
la sauce guèye a promis robert il ya un
moment quand tu critiques giné court 10
ans qui fait de la soupe et tu fais
exactement la même chose que gynéco tu
m'excuses à l oral c'est une musique
comme une autre il ya de la variété mais
vous ne faisait pas de variation
anormale vieux cesseront de la variété
c'est tout temps coûte enfants leur
projet au lieu où se serrait
alors votre vrai nom c'est donc charles
ambush d'origine camerounaise née en 67
père comptable mère dactylo et vous êtes
5e 10 sur une famille de 12 voilà alors
quand vous avez neuf ans vos parents
divorcent et votre père supporte pas et
vous dites il repasse il repasse votre
mère et son nouveau mec dans un parking
voilà 37 rue saint forgeot en 77 moins
doués à repasser ça veut dire assassiné
quand fasciné les assassiner comment
c'est d'abord il a touché mon pays la
touche et le conjoint vos murs ouais et
après il s'est occupé de ma mère ouais
moi j'appelle ça c'est celle ash ouais
c'est sita début on t'as pas besoin de
faire tout ça en plus si la personne
veut plutôt à ça lui dire au revoir mais
bon voilà salut à part amener votre mère
en tous les cas ça va pas me ramener non
plus mais voilà voilà ensuite visite il
part en calèche c'est à dire en prison
il ya il a pris combien votre père bon à
mon père il a fait en tous sens et qui
gênent oui c'est à dire tous les jeux
c'est pas beaucoup bah ouais cinq mois
après il a fait autant que moi pour
braquo ouais voilà pourquoi bon on y
mentionnait le crime passionnel et en
plus c'est là il a eu du bol plus que
il a échappé au couperet ouais bien 81
81 2 c'est la peine de mort et est
témoin révisé pendant 70 ans donc j'ai
pas capté on voit la tête après cinq
années pour braconnage web braconnage g
soleure pour annoncer
il est où votre père mon père il doit
être à duplex inquiète par par la whey
ça va c'est son problème et vous le
voyez payera cher choix ouais voilà donc
vous à l'époque vous partez à la dass
vous parlez de la dass en expliquant que
finalement les abus sexuels sont très
fréquents c'est fréquent est beaucoup
plus fréquent que les gens croient ve et
le bizutage
le bizutage est fréquent et le problème
c'est pour revenir maintenant
avec les ctf qu'ils essayent de faire je
sors des centres techniques éducatif
ouais dans un centre technique éducatif
tu apprends qu à une chose savoir que
ceux qui ont ce qu'on te promets
n'existe pas moi je veux un coup un
numéro donc tu doit rapporter tu es déjà
adultes avant l'âge mais donc la société
va tu sais que ceci est une variante va
rien amené c'est que du pipeau ouais et
le problème dans ces trucs là c'est
quand vous êtes enfermé pour ce qu'ils
ont de la famille c'est bien pour ce
qu'ils n'ont pas faut se démerder donc
abus sexuels de toutes sortes et quand
vous avez une petite greluche qui passe
ça y va aussi vous dites temps meilleurs
amis c'est à fourchette très ton
meilleur ami c'est ta fourchette parce
que quand ils rentrent à 13 ans quand tu
aurais tu as concurrentes à 13 ans en
maison de correction puisque c'est comme
ça c'était fou centre technique éducatif
vaut mieux avoir deux trois poteaux
quant à 13 ans car on aura moins de
problèmes avec ceux de 17 contre quand
vous rentrez vous en avais 12 10 il ya
peut-être d'autres problèmes avec ce 17
mai qui justement n'ont pas de bons
rapports sexuels avec la gente féminine
s'occuperont les plus petits voilà alors
à 17 ans vous vous retrouvez à paris et
là vous découvrez le hip hop mais la
branche dure du hip hop à la dépouille
1 la dépouille était un moyen de 2
becqueter survivre voilà braqueurs quoi
ouais ces braqueurs de petite envergure
les petits faubourg un rapide une paire
de chaussures et la rapine son brave et
rapide tout doucement
c'était pas des banques qua non les
banques c'est venu plus tard il a failli
à l'enfer 2 basé e l'acheminement social
justement vous faites les petits
institutions jusqu'à aller jusqu en
calèche en calèche vous apprenez l'école
du vice et
dehors ben c'est soirée ratée puis
juniors où on casse dalle non mais
franchement préféré l'autre ouais vous
êtes dans le gangsta rap à ce moment là
non non j'ai j'écoutais du games europe
mais vous vous circulez avec les requins
vicieux quand même c'est pas des mecs
très à elle retient vicieux sont mes
amis dont les cousins mais les requins
ambitieux avant tout c'est une famille
on était justement ce qu'on s'est servi
de substitut parce qu'on avait pas chez
nous zoua aperçoit une mère est
forcément les plus faibles à ce fonds
occuper les plus gros est dedans il faut
manger donc chacun son activité iii et
mérite salaire et voilà voilà alors à un
moment ça commence à sentir le roussi
pour vous un charge et vous partez en
allemagne et là vous tombez pour
braquage j'ai fait cinq ans que thomas
ben moi vite yao mobile peggle 1 c'était
une bonne expérience car dans les
mauvaises il faut apprendre et dans les
bonnes il faut apprendre aussi et là
j'étais dans une mauvaise mais elle m'a
servi de
beaucoup servi cheveux db limite je
maintenant je commence à jacter de troie
qui l'engagent en plus ouais
on va réellement bien quand même un
problème qu'est ce que ça vous a appris
à part à part l'allemand à part
l'allemand que
quand vous arrivez par exemple dans un
beau pays comme la france où
théoriquement c'est l'eldorado et on
voit réseau où on vous accueille avec un
grand sourire 1 alors que de l'autre
côté est théoriquement c'est des fois
chaude et nous en asie alors que vous
pouvez trouver un travail en ayant
quatre épingles sur le sur le parent on
vous voit rien tandis qu'en france ce
fait la même chose en d'autres endroits
alors parce que l'habit fait le moine à
vous ressortez de cette eau là à berlin
à 27 ans au total vous avez quand même
été enfermés dix sept ans si on fait le
convoi s'est dirigé la vache et cette
pige avec la calèche ne faisait pas
attendu le rap pour être révolté vous en
tous les cas non pas du tout alors vous
disiez tout à l'heure que joey starr
faisait du doc gynéco ce cas un peu
exagéré mais non vous c'est gynéco qui
vous a demandé de devenir rap est alors
au début je n'avais rien à [ __ ] vous
deviez faire un bouquin au départ oui au
départ je voulais faire un bouquin ouais
puisque je voulais toucher une autre
partie de la populace est bon gyneco il
m'a appelé
et je me suis pris au jeu voilà et ça
vous plaît ouais c'est mort alors vous
en êtes vous avec la justice maintenant
avec la justice bas ça va j'ai juste
cinq ans de mise à l'épreuve et pour
cocaïne ouais pourquoi il pourra vous
donner de la cocaïne ah ouais je survis
1 je survis il faut il faut le savoir
moi quand on me dit l'argent sale c'est
vrai l'argent sale mais l'argent sale à
la rive sur quelle table vous regardez
ce qu'ils font leurs trucs là avec leur
pétrole et leur baratin à gauche à
droite on se dit c'est que l'argent
propre mais celle là quand il va en
calèche s'ils vont jamais un mois j'ai
besoin de manger je suis dans un bled où
je suis né où j'ai su pupille de la
nation ça fait 8 qui gémit j'ai pas mes
faf voulait dire j'ai pas mes fans
n'avaient pas de papiers pas de papiers
je suis d ici j'ai fait l'armée j'ai été
exemptés à chaque fois que j'ai quelques
mois comme sera baratta de francs 50
ouais donc un moment je me dis hé les
gars voulaient pas que baic je vais
becqueter même si je dois aller à l'ara
teulière j ai relaté hier mais j'irai
manger parce que la vie c'est pas
attendre la partie qu elle a raté les
uns c'est la prison c'est pas la calèche
assez la même qu'à tel qui allège donjon
raté hier à l'impact et blaise alain
paquet vous avez peur de retourner en
prison
c'est pas que j'ai peur de retourner en
prison mais je voudrais pas y aller way
with its et l'anpe du vice c'est là une
peu difficile a aucune réinsertion tu
n'auras jamais ton prochain larcins
c'est clair je suis resté douze mois
avec un gus s'appelait josée-anne entier
qu'ils aient des bras qu à l'ancienne
les postes etc
et moi je suis rentré dedans n'est en
n'ayant rien fait ou même en ayant
offert un petit vice pendant 12 mois
j'ai appris en théorie comment braquer
ouais c'est tout ouais les mecs étaient
nommés course était mon prof fait c'est
pas très bon prof si le mec il est
derrière les barreaux simple et ne c'est
pas grave tu apprends des erreurs des
autres diack c'est quelque chose à dire
non parce que président américain aurait
des mecs comme lui mais j'écoute avec
avec attention je redis la manière de
raconter sa vie qui est qui qui touche
qui est très proche d'audiard ses vrais
rivaux pas seulement écrire des du rap
est vrai qu'il ya des films maintenant
un bain
sarkozy les lois sarkozy vous en pensez
quoi chauffer c'est du réchauffé c'est
du réchauffé du réchauffé qu'est ce qui
va changer ils parlent les tapant à
longueur de journée tu vas sur le périph
qui vinrent au titre fait si ces
intrigues ses fines
hockey
sarkozy attend parce que ça ça m'a fait
rigoler c'est une carte des bons clients
tu peux revenir quand tu me
charles vous croyez en quoi je crois en
moi ouais l'amour
oui mais c'est malheureux de croire en
l'amour et c'est malheureux d'être
amoureux mais pas croire en l'amour
ouais voilà votre mère elle vous aime je
pense que ouais ouais votre grand mère
aussi ouais mais c'est aussi ma fille
aussi donc vous croyez au moins à
l'amour de ces trois femmes ouais ça
c'est clair ça s'arrête là ouais vous
croyez en dieu
pas du tout pourquoi pas parce qu'il ya
eu il n'est jamais venu au parloir
j'avais vu
et j'avais vu au parloir et je pense que
quel est le père qui laisserait crevé
ses gosses sans jamais bougé le petit
doigt
meyer savent quand même c'est la faute
des âmes ouais le medef aussi
cette année le tient je ne fais pas la
porte mais aussi alors donc voilà donc
dont je t'emmerde on l'a dit tout à
l'heure avec béatrice dalle vous tapez
sur l'intégralité du rap français même
joey starr qui pourtant me semblait à
l'abri quand même ce genre de d'attac
alors on va me faire une interview si on
disait du bien
[Musique]
alors ça même si jean gabin si on disait
du bien de joey starr vous diriez quoi
ça a été un précurseur à moi tu vois si
on disait du bien de kery james et vous
diriez quoi bon rappeur way de kool shen
récurent sur de lord kossity grande
saucisse à vous arrivez pas alors que
j'arrivais pas à dire du bien de l'ordre
que c'est justement un ss et pit
baccardi
pit baccardi bon pique assiette ouais
pitié
vous avez vous aller taguer où les
enfants surprises sont formidables si le
décor ils leur font mais j'ai
l'impression excuse moi quand même si
leur foi envers
beaucoup changé de sap a beaucoup changé
l'esprit pour toute chose à lady laistee
où
vous
joli petit arrière train des nouveaux
seins tout neuf à
m 6 à la belge lui tire mon chapeau
c'est l'un des rares qui est toujours là
ouais ouais à la rédac adamo comme un
ipad il a pas tourné savez s'il arrivait
un que le même avec la même j'avance du
début jusqu'à la fin que la cena dans la
variante salut je suis là
la rumeur
j'écoute pas trop soucié politicards
c'est pas mal à la rumeur les
investisseurs chacun sa soupe
voilà quoi doc gynéco ouais merci mon
pote
voilà mais ce qui fait comme les est ce
qui fait qu musique-là var y est il le
dira mais il
est vraiment un lé dos mais à moins de
succès qu'avant à la roue tourne ouais
mais bon je pense qu'il a il a fait son
job voilà et puis si maintenant il veut
tirer sa révérence qu'il attire ce que
beaucoup devraient faire d'ailleurs un
effet avoir les moyens de tirer sa
révérence arionas ça fait déjà 10 piges
qui sont là parce qu'ils ont pris ça y
est ils ont rêvé dentier maintenant
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux